blotz porte
condamnée pour avoir envoyé superman en
réa avec une balle en crypto n'est pas
question d'entrer dans votre swing sound
ce code l'avenir le dira
j'ai bien trop basse le tribunal emma
d'un mois leur a dit que tu pourrais
m'aider nous allons arrêter mais n'en
sait pas plus il vous sort mais madame
wade c'est aux armes
[Musique]
je ne reviendrai pas ce genre
d'extrémité si cette mission n'était pas
d'une importance que vous ne pouvez même
pas imaginer
vous êtes partant ou restant bien
montons votre équipe
chaque coéquipier ou coéquipières est
choisi pour sa panoplie d'aptitudes sans
pareil
[Musique]
désolé d'être à la bouche j'ai dû aller
faire car ça c'est du lourd
c'est quoi ça un chien un chien ça et
qu'est ce que c'est que ce serait comme
race de clébard moi je dirais lévrier
afghan n'est pas vrai non car on va bien
côté dans l'eau car on veut sortir c'est
pas le gard où c'est qu'une boulette qui
fait de mal à personne enfin hockey à
part 27 go scala bouffer mais bon
votre mission est de détruire toute
trace d'une sorte des toiles de mer
connu sous le seul nom de projet star
touche ya des questions
ce nom c'est parce qu en argot étoiles
de mer ca veut dire [ __ ]
nom dit tout donc non
on y va
ces deux suicides en effet notre
spécialité
je suis un super héros
[Musique]
c'est nos pères
de sortir de là vivante c'est moi qui
vais te sortir des limbes y va
deux mois
[Musique]
ratatouille aux rapports bijoux
nana oui on comporte pas la radio